so you're staying in a hotel that's like
literally walking distance from where
Kennedy was whacked I did it on purpose
yeah did you this is my fourth time
coming to Addison I take the tour every
year and every year you do the JFK tour
every year we do the government JFK tour
government I want that well-documented
government tour where they spiel the
[ __ ] to us but I know I know all the
stuff at you know that it's I called out
to it didn't happen then it happened
everyone calm down that gonna happen
that did not happen show so you you go
in no way I know
I call [ __ ] wrong that was over here
at this actually five shots they say -
there's five three mess one in the
throat one hit in the back who's on this
tour just local tourist interest who
don't know [ __ ] so I fill them in what's
this is what's weird
yeah is so my brother Derek my feature
and then ass on my opener MC when we
walk around I'm like explain like stuff
I know but there there's the homeless
community around there all black guys
for a reason yeah they come up and
they're like oh you don't know [ __ ] you
know and they this like their gig here
in Dallas oh so they're giving another
tour it's a side tour like what really
happened Wow like a meth homeless guy
yeah it's actually pretty interesting
respect I bet there I bet it's more
educational than the government shill
tour correct yeah yeah you know how in
Venice or like third Street the bums are
like out there like maybe chuckling
maybe it's the one-man band
yeah be there eating glass yeah these
that's their kind of third street
interesting Venice is an interesting
thing to me because I love Muscle Beach
yeah because it's a bunch of gay guys
who've cured themselves of AIDS by
lifting weights you're right I mean it's
just dudes that should have died 93 look
at Arnold yeah and they just somehow
have pumped themselves free of AIDS
it's impressive just I mean it's wild
another reason to work out yeah do you
have you ever gone down there I grew up
in Venice you grew up in Venice yeah in
the summers my dad would my uncle lived
there so we would me and my brother go
out there every summer so we'd work out
Gold's jazz my shoe or an athlete from
the beginning uh yes and no I mean yeah
I'm I grew up playing sport
but in in Venice it was like we go then
the summers me my brother just hanging
on the boardwalk wheat my dad would give
us like our allowance for the week and
we'd buy fake Rolexes and we collect
them then go back home and sell them to
the kids for way more expensive prices
so you were a business guy as a hustle
you were smart
from the beginning buy the fake Rolexes
on the Venice Boardwalk yeah sell them
to your friends how old a 9 8 or 9 year
olds buying fake Rolexes yeah where was
this going out where where is Laura
you've been Aurora at Colorado where
they had the shooting all the shootings
yeah